alors non c'est bon vous pouvez
continuer à manger aujourd'hui on ne va
parler que de choses propres et en plus
on n'en est pas là le mois d'avril
arrive à grands pas et c'est cool parce
que ça va être l'occasion de nous
rencontrer
ça va mais m les occasions de nous
et oui parce que j'ai de nouvelles
pompes
[Musique]
si vous êtes parisienne parisien
francilienne franciliens ou si vous avez
la possibilité de venir à paris sachez
que je serai les 8 et 9 avril prochains
à vidéo city paraît alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas vidéo city paris c'est
un peu comme le salon de l'agriculture
sauf que à la place des animaux et des
produits du terroir badiou buzz et des
youtube il ya mois vous pourrez venir au
choix du nom siroter nous déguster ou
flatter nos plages soyons tous nos plats
d' soyeuse
non en réalité c'est une immense
convention qui se déroule à paris porte
de versailles et qui regroupe un nombre
impressionnant de youtube 2 et du tube
aller voir la liste sur le site ça donne
juste le vertige avec au programme des
dédicaces des animations des
interventions sur scène bref venez me
voir
ça me ferait plaisir vraiment alors vous
allez me dire oui les où il y en a
toujours cas pour parer ans déjà et
ensuite je vous réponds que j'étais il
ya pas si longtemps au japan tour
festival et à tour donc pas à paris mais
je vais aussi vous répondre que je
serais aussi au zénith de strasbourg les
22 et 23 avril pour la troisième édition
de l'année aux castes qui est aussi une
convention avec un nombre incroyable
d'invités incroyable pareil je vous
invite à aller voir sur leur site y a
que du beau linge et un programme aux
petits oignons
là aussi il y aura des animations des
dédicaces des conférences des rencontres
des workshops comme d'hab je vous mets
tous les liens dans la description du
chouchou teint hâlé puis comme vraiment
je vous chouchoute je vous propose de
vous faire gagner des places gratuites
ou des places à tarif réduit pour ces
deux conventions ça rendez vous sur la
page facebook de dans ton corps
le lien est ou dont dans la description
voilà donc ça fait deux belles occasions
de se rencontrer dans le mois qui vient
on aura sûrement d'autres après dans
d'autres villes je vous tiens au courant
voilà donc venez je venais
là
[Musique]
ah merde tu te remets pas là
portez vous bien